welcome back to glamour unfiltered
hosted by me josh smith and today
we are joined by the queen of badassery
it's maisie williams
it is well you've literally gone from
slaying
mythical people to then literally
slaying people
irl on this show but again in a very
niche way
yeah it is it there are definite
similarities which is what i was so
drawn to
um but yeah it was just like
totally a lot more fun and like a lot
more heart light-hearted
and not so much trauma and more laughter
what do you think you've learned about
yourself through playing this role
i guess like kim um
kim really sees just like the truth
in everything and sees things for what
they are
and um is almost like very childlike in
that sense
and i am the queen of overthinking
everything
and to play someone and to like
just work through a scene playing
someone who
um just read things reads things for
what they are
and doesn't think twice that was really
like
was just really freeing just shut your
brain up
and do the scene and have some like
quiet
within yourself and just like watch
other people
and like feed off of them and and like
get outside of
your head and just like be in the room
and i think like that
is like a great lesson for me and i
hadn't thought about it until you asked
me that question that maybe i should be
doing a little bit more of that in my
life
you've always tended to end up on jobs
where there's this amazing camaraderie
right this amazing teamwork like
you have this it's not in just a
sisterhood it's a brotherhood it's a
peoplehood
um how much has that teamwork
helped you at different times in your
career so time you can remember
teamwork really bringing you through and
picking you up honestly like that most
the most common time is on on a film set
i think
that these people see like the best and
worst of you
because you're just with each other
constantly
i do get a lot of energy from other
people and i do
really rely on other people to like pick
me up
because i'm really not good at doing
that myself
and so when i can get on a set and
really get on with people
it will always make me do a better job
um because i have done a couple of
things where i haven't got on as well
with people and i
when i watch the film i can see it and
i'm like oh i
can see that i couldn't do it as well
because i feed off other people so much
i think as well this character has this
weird upbringing she's survivalist she's
been protected from reality right and
she's
looking in from the outside
have you ever felt in your life a bit of
an outsider
looking in yeah all the time
um because like at school i
i wasn't in like the cool group and as
much as i was like i don't really want
to be in the core group
i really wanted to be part
i never really knew the how to go about
it and i always went about it in the
wrong ways and i was like
when i was insecure instead of being
friendly i was like the opposite where i
would like put up barriers and things
like that and i think that's quite
common for a lot of people
and so then when i started acting all of
a sudden this caught the attention of
people and they were like what's this
girl doing here who we don't know how is
she an actress you know
but then i ended up being an outsider
because
even though i was inside the acting
world i was even further outside of like
the reality world
that i lived every single day and
because i'd never trained to be an actor
or because i
started when i was really young i didn't
really feel like i was in the acting
crowd i didn't really have acting
friends or anything like that
and so i've definitely felt like an
outsider so much and
i think even you know being an actress
for over a decade now
like i still always feel like i guess
it's like imposter syndrome right where
you're like oh
is this really is this really what i'm
supposed to be doing like am i
actually gonna do this for the rest of
my life and so i think
it's like i think like with so many
people you just always feel
yeah and i think that's just like the
human brain to be honest with you maybe
i should just stop
overthinking everything and start just
doing like you right going out
and having the dinners having the
brunches but instead i'm sitting my bed
like
maybe no one wants me maybe i shouldn't
go out maybe i shouldn't leave the house
so yeah it's just it is what it is have
you dealt with that in security and land
to
kind of park it at certain times um
i think it's just trying to spend
just at the moment i'm in it right i'm
that that um heim song
now i'm in it that's really speaking to
me because i really am
in that right now and i think just
listening to yourself
and i think that that's the hardest
thing to do
is like truly know who you are
and and you know as an actor or as any
person of influence like you do these
interviews right and people want to know
your opinion on everything
and i think like admitting that you i
don't have an opinion on
everything because i don't know
everything about everything and i'm
trying to figure out what really
interests me and what doesn't
um and i think just being able to like
admit that and
like own that i don't know everything
that's what i'm trying to do so next
topic of conversation is trump
so i really want to get your opinion on
that
but i think this is also a really
interesting coming of
age story isn't it when
you feel like you had that turning point
for you
that coming of age moment i mean it's
always ongoing isn't it but is there a
time you were like
wow this feels like a turning point i
moved out when i was really young and i
was quite alone
but then by the time i turned sort of
like 18
19 everyone else had like sort of moved
out and gone to uni and things like that
and i i got this group of friends who
are still my friends now
um and we would just go out all the time
and i lived in bath at the time um
and we uh
would just party every weekend
and go out and it would just be the same
thing and then another sunday we'd go
for some brunch
and then everyone would go back to work
and then like in the next weekend we'd
do it all over again and it was like the
perfect summer when we go to all these
music festivals
and that was a time when like finally i
felt like i was doing something that
people like that other people were doing
my age and i felt like
normal for the first time you know like
i fitted somewhere
and i guess yeah that was just like a
really amazing
moment for me because i just as we said
like
i'd always felt like i was outside
looking in you know
and like for the first time i was like
oh i just i belong with these people
and i feel like a normal person and i
felt
just like i was thriving and it was
excellent my
sense of belonging is the greatest gift
of all though isn't it when you feel
like you're really in it
you feel accepted and then you then get
to accept yourself right
absolutely and it's just like amazing
because all of these
things that didn't make sense before and
all of these like questions that you are
asking
they just all float away and you're like
oh i just this is all i
i wanted and all i needed what did you
used to ask yourself
like that oh gosh this is like
very very deep
i don't know um you just ask yourself
why am i
an actress why me why did this happen to
me what is it about me
that's interesting and okay so if it's
this this and this why do
i not think that's very cool and what do
i think is cool in other people and why
do i always think the grass is greener
and yeah it's just like
big first world problems honestly and
one of the things that i love about this
as well
is the combat scenes you know you're
rolling around on that floor
you love a combat scene obviously
everyone knows this about you
but just that level of strength that it
takes to do that give you
more faith in your body and your
strength as a person
outside of work as well
i suppose it really does because i think
like so many people
i i struggle to do exercise
and because i can't run for very far or
i can't you know do these things or i
feel like i can't
i always think that i'm like weak and
like oh i can't do it and like i think
that that reflects on like
something on the inside you know because
like in the marathon which is like not a
big deal you know
i don't know when i'm doing something
like that
i really can do it and i can thrive and
i'll do it until six in the morning or
like however long it takes and
so i guess it's just like you've just
got to find what fits haven't you
and like for me it's these elaborate
combat scenes in film
like i must take this role because i
need the workout
for the first time in two years i will
actually be doing some physical
exercises
and i guess as well it makes you have a
greater faith in your body image as well
so you're like this is a strong
machine yeah exactly
this is a good look this is something
that people should aspire to
like this is good this is a good image
this is a good thing to be putting out
to the world
um and yeah this is what
should inspire people yeah
yeah that's what we're about all about
the inspiration
the high kicks the punches the slaying
you know is was there a time when you
were doing the
um stunts on set for this show where i
went a little bit wrong
yeah um there's this bit
so there's a lot of bottle throwing
right there's like a bougie
kind of like sleazy bar in the bottom in
the basement of this guy's house
and so there's like bottles of booze
everywhere
and so they come out and they're being
thrown
um and i got i think i got like three or
four bottles on the head
and i was really sad about it but when
you're on a film set you don't want to
cry
like a child like someone hit me on
there
but it's like late you know and emotions
are running high but i was like i'm not
gonna cry
because like it doesn't solve anything
um
but then the night after there's the
high kicks to the chest
and i um i really did
clip clip uh jimmy's what do you call it
like a grill in right gold tea
and i just clipped his face
shawn's like yeah and um i think his
mouth ended up bleeding
and so then we were even and it was fine
and he didn't cry so i was like i'm glad
i didn't cry
maisie you're a bit of a menace wow
it's a dangerous world you've been so
lucky to have
an amazing decade of a career already
at this young age and you've already had
amazing success does the success
you've had give you less or more
pressure going forward
um i don't know about
less or more pressure it makes me
so much more
[Music]
i guess just like opinionated and like i
just criticize
everything i love everything that
everyone else does and then anything
that i do i'm like but was that really
good or was it really right or
you know at the time i was like yes this
is the decision that i should be making
and then
when it's coming out i'm like oh gosh
was it right you know is this how i want
to be seen
and i think that's just my my own
pressure on myself really
do i want to be like um in
these kind of movies or these kind of
movies and like you know i've watched a
lot of young actors and then
sort of watch the career after their
breakout role
and actually the ones i really idolize
are the ones where people like
whatever happened to them you know and
actually i think that they've been doing
really great movies but they're just
maybe
not seen by like a lot of people but
they're clearly doing something that
they really
love and so i've wanted to go more down
that route
and so i know that that's never really
going to be
like people are never going to see that
as success in their eyes because
they saw me on the biggest show on on tv
that there ever was and so like
how are you ever going to go up from
that and like for me it's not really
about going up from there it's about
like
exploring this whole world that i
haven't had the opportunity to
yeah and doing it on your own path
like that's like a very strong message
and realization to have because not you
know like to take control of your own
destiny in that situation is kind of
amazing isn't it
yeah definitely i think that um
yeah there's just like so you know it's
amazing to get to this point in my
career because there's so many people
that are like what do you want to do
like what is it that you want and like
you know if you've never asked yourself
that question then it's really hard to
tell people and so
you know for me it's just been figuring
out what that is and i'm so lucky that i
have these people that can enable
me to do things and
yeah but you know answering that
question is like half of the battle i
think
it is and if you could sit the u that
was starting off on game of thrones on
this scene call
she was dialing into your house i'm her
new look for me um
what would you want to say to him what
do you think should say to you i would
want
her to just like
enjoy being a kid and just like do all
of this other fun stuff
um and just like be
allow i just wanted to allow myself to
be more free i used to be just so
neurotic and overthink everything
and i guess she would probably say to me
um
[Music]
that you don't know anything and shove
[Laughter]
you don't know me you don't know me
she's sassy isn't she
she was she was just like
i don't know had a lot of emotions
like child emotions you know what i mean
yes i love speaking to you
i think you're great thank you i love
with you too this has been really fun
you